okay let's get to this day in history
this day in history this is a big one on
this day in history the Roman Empire
officially began now I'm not going to go
through the entirety of the Roman Empire
in our last you know a few minutes here
so let's focus on one incredible
historical coincidence at the outset of
the Roman Empire that might shed some
light on the nature of the world of the
physical world in the metaphysical world
the Roman Empire began when Gaius Julius
Caesar Octavian whose active ian is
frequently cold air to the assassinated
Julius Caesar was granted the title
augustus by the Roman Senate
so Augustus ruled from January 16th 27
BC until its death in AD 14 after the
demise of the second triumvirate which
was formed by himself Marc Anthony and
Marcus Lepidus to defeat the assassins
of Julius Caesar Augustus restored the
semblance of the Roman Republic here
there was the Senate and the legislators
and all that the semblance of it in
reality he retained firm rule for
himself there's much to note about
Augustus but consider just this one fact
Augustus was not actually the son of
Caesar he was his adopted son he was
regularly referred to as d-v filius son
of a god because upon julius caesar's
death a comet known as caesar's comment
appeared above the earth it was the
brightest comet in recorded history
having even a negative absolute
magnitude it could be seen even by
daylight and was taken as a sign that
caesar had been deified turned into a
god upon his death and so the son of a
god rained on a throne in rome and
initiated the PAC's agustí the piece of
Augustan the Peace of Rome of so much of
the civilized world that blanketed the
land
I was so named by Seneca the younger and
considered a miracle because of the
widespread war which had a wreaked havoc
for so many centuries prior at that same
time during that same reign another
bright light appeared in the sky over
Bethlehem to signal precisely the coming
of another king a king whose kingdom is
not of this world
a king who would be called not
phileas DB but Phileas day not son of a
god or the divinity but son of the one
true God himself and a king who would
bring not just peace for a time and a
space but for all time and space into
eternity a coincidence so incredible an
example of God's wimzie's so undeniable
and yet it's almost never taught in
history class or physics class or
astronomy class
Alexander Pope put it well all nature is
but art unknown to the all chance
direction which thou canst not see